aux abords d'un terrain de futsal le
maillot de lionel messi est toujours
omniprésent les jeunes joueurs saint
quentinois rêve d'imiter le quadruple
ballon d'or dans ses dribbles unique et
le futsal n'est pas aussi abordable
techniquement que son grand frère
l'extérieur n'est pas obligé de mettre
les crampons et puis les cachots petit
donc sont un petit peu plus difficile
donc ses meilleurs
amis de votre location plus petit et une
terra est réduit
mais dès qu'il se met la vie on apprend
on connait plus de personne et aime bien
cette ambiance à deux équipes de cinq
s'affrontent le gardien doit dégager le
ballon à la main et les touches
s'effectue au pied contrairement au
football en plein air le ballon ne
décolle quasiment jamais du sol le jeu
est fait de passes courtes de gestes
techniques comme le célèbre passements
de jambes le futsal réclame plus
d'endurance les distances étant plus
courte qu'à l'extérieur le temps de
réaction doit être élevée pour que les
enchaînements soit pas assez rapide les
petits espaces fait pour les manieurs de
ballon les joueurs techniques s'en
sortiront très très bien en salle parce
que techniquement aussi sont à l'aise à
l'extérieur 1 re en salle ça doit être
pareil et pour les grands dribbleurs
c'est l'occasion de pouvoir se régaler
dans ce genre de
et ce quelle que soit la taille du
terrain le plaisir de jouer ensemble
domine pendant 12 minutes de marche